-I wanted to ask you.
-Yes.
-There's sort of a very
memorable bathroom scene
in the film.
-Oh, yes.
-And you actually posted a photo
of -- this is Austria.
-It is. This is where
we shot "Downhill."
-Whoo!
-Whoo! Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-We have an Austrian.
-Austria!
-Whoo!
-This is an actual sign
in Austria.
-It is, in fact.
-This person's gonna regre
"Whoo-ing."
[ Laughter ]
Those are things
not to do in the bathroom.
-You're gonna have to
zoom in on this.
-Yeah. So that --
That's a real weird one.
-Little tighter.
-Not like the crouch
on the top there,
and then --
[ Laughter ]
...and then that just seem
like, what do you --
-Yeah.
-What do you think
the message is there?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
"Please do not give [bleep
to this bathroom."
[ Laughter ]
And that is an actual sign
-It's a real issue in Austria.
[ Laughter ]
She knows.
-And she will know.
[ Laughter ]
As she will attest to.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Did you --
I mean, it's beautiful.
-You can see,
I was really confused.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause I wasn't -- I had neve
heard of these rules before.
[ Laughter ]
And, anyway, I had to, like,
rethink everything.
-Yeah.
I don't think it's confused.
I think it's, like,
your best-laid plans
are thrown out the window.
[ Laughter ]
-But I find that confusing
-Right.
-It's wrecking --
It's ruining your mind.
-You have a whole day planne
that's gonna end
in a bathroom in Vienna --
-Yeah. Yeah.
Did you get to explore?
It's such a beautiful place.
Did you get around, Will?
Did you see other parts of -
-Uh, well, I -- we got to ski...
-Yeah.
-...every weekend that we were
off, which was incredible.
-And we got to ski
while we were filming, too
-Sure.
-We did it all the time.
-I got lost in Switzerland
-Okay, so --
[ Laughter ]
-No joke, yeah.
-But the film's in Austria
-The film's in Austria.
-Tell what happened.
[ Laughter ]
-But the one resort
that we were in,
the second resort we were in
called Ischgl,
shares the border, and I -
there was little signs, like
"This way, Switzerland."
I'm like, "Let's do it."
[ Laughter ]
So I'm by myself.
I'm skiing down.
I was like,
"This is so lovely," and..
But I don't see
a chairlift back at all.
[ Laughter ]
And I end up in a small town
in Switzerland.
[ Laughter ]
Gone for like three hours.
I have to figure out, like
a bus and a tram.
-And you had no money.
-I had no money.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I'm not skiing with any
And the Swiss are nasty.
[ Laughter ]
You don't want to --
to get cornered
by a bunch of Swiss,
chanting at me.
-Bad people.
-Pelting me with Rolex watches
[ Laughter ]
Hard chocolate candies.
-So very --
-It was harrowing.
-Yeah, it sounds harrowing
And you made your way back
-I mean, I felt like a big boy
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Quietly, I'm on a bus,
I'm like,
"Do you know
how to get back to Ischgl?
They're like,
"Yes. Just follow us."
And so I followed
this group of people.
-Did you have --
Were you more worried abou
making it back or the fact
that you'd be gone so long
that the people
in the film would notice?
-I was panicked because I woul
have to call production
to come pick me up
in Switzerland.
[ Laughter ]
Which, from where we were --
is like a three-hour drive
-Yeah.
-So six hours round trip,
and then --
-Yeah.
-...they would be bummed,
and I would have
committed resources
that were needed elsewhere
to picking me up.
-Who is the better skier
of the two of you?
-Julia. Yeah.
I'll just say it.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
-I'll own it.
I'll own it.
-She's very good.
-However, Nat Faxon,
who's one of our
two co-directors,
is the best skier.
-He's the best.
-Yes, he is.
-Gotcha.
-Yeah.
-And would the crew sort of sa
you're all equally good,
or was the crew honest?
-Well, if they were smart,
they would.
-Yeah.
-But --
-You had to say that
in front of the producer.
-Right.
-Yeah.
-But actually, the crew were -
We had the most amazing crew
because a bunch of them
had to ski, of course,
to make this movie,
and ski backwards
with cameras on their backs.
-Yeah.
-Oh, man.
-So, I mean, the whole thing
was just --
-That would bum me out
if I was maybe just
an okay skier
trying to do my part.
-Yeah.
-And thinking, like,
over the course of the film,
"I'm getting
a little bit better,"
but every time you go out,
some guy's skiing backward
with a camera.
-Totally.
-"I'm not good at this."
-At all.
-It does sharpen your focus,
when you're skiing on camera
and the guy's skiing backwards
and having conversations
and pulling focus.
[ Laughter ]
-Pulling focus.
Talking to you in an ear thing
[ Laughter ]
-And just, like -- and you'r
like, "Okay, don't wreck.
Don't wreck."
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah, it's -- it's...
-We're gonna bring out
the writers and directors,
Nat and Jim, right after this.
-Oh, my God.
-And we're gonna talk some more.
-Okay.
-We're gonna have a bunch of you
out here together.
Julia and Will.